I am the new health and safety advisor
here at Cheyenne Mountain I've been
asked to do a series of video entries
um as part of the record
um to send back to the senator oversight
committee I have experience working with
the military but I have to admit working
at Stargate command is a little
different to anything I've previously
experienced I've been here a couple of
weeks now
and already the go go gold I've tried to
attack the Earth and nearly destroyed us
apparently it was only sg1 that from
what I can tell through look
say saved us all
um it's quite alarming
um also they're literally like their
next mission
one of the members of sg1 got taken over
by one of these gold things and became
one of them briefly
um apparently it's a good gold and then
that that's okay apparently but I mean
I've got to write a risk assessment for
that how am I supposed to rear to risk
assessment for an alien snake that jumps
in the back of your head and takes over
your body and you can't tell unless for
some reason their eyes glow
I mean so many needs to look into the
medical implications of your eyes
glowing for a star I don't even know
where to start writing the risk
assessment for that
wear a collar I don't I don't under so
apparently though I'm not to worry
it's just been a heavy week
apparently
um it's not like this normally after
speaking to General Hammond a couple of
times now I've been reassured that you
know most of the missions don't go that
way and that actually sg1 in particular
at the best at what they do and that I
really shouldn't be too concerned
here a week
the week
it's just over a month in
I think these people could really do
some sort of non-interference policy
I'm certain I've seen sci-fi shows on
the Telly in the past and they weren't
allowed to like interfere with other
species because it generally doesn't go
well
well sg1 again and I'm starting to
notice a pattern here sg1 again with two
missions
a one they got trapped in some sort of
virtual reality
Universe because they just wandered in
and then another one
um they released a biochemist terrorist
basically
because they thought she was on their
side because they got imprisoned doing
something
I mean what are these I've got meetings
with us they keep putting it back and
keeping it up but I'm locking them down
I'm speaking to sg1 in the next week and
they will be told
very straight that health and safety
matters
I've just completed my meetings with sg1
for the first time
um the team is
slightly unusual they're not all
military personnel for start which is is
I appreciate it very unusual they're led
by a colonel O'Neil two else he said
that
several times
um
he doesn't seem to quite grasp what
we're trying to do here with the health
and safety initiative
um he made several sarcastic comments
and generally speaking I'm not sure he
was listening for much of the discussion
um I'm just really hoping that at least
some of what I was saying got through
and that he won't do anything too stupid
um
I'm absolutely similarities an excellent
military officer and I'm sure the what I
saw was just what I get sometimes from
the military is it's like contempt for
the health and safety but I'm confident
I'll win him over
number two in command is a captain
Samantha Carter she was lovely
until I suggested that the cable
management in this building was a bit of
a problem and she got a bit snarky but
you know generally though I don't think
we'll get any major problems from
Captain Carter
she seems to really be a very very
intelligent woman and I'm certain she
won't do anything that's going to cause
me any problems
didn't didn't say anything at all
not a word
nothing
wouldn't even say hello
Daniel Jackson is the one that I'm
actually relieved about
he seems to be very intelligent he was
more than willing to engage me he took a
lot of what I've seen on board he
actually had some very useful and
sensible insights into things that we
can do within the base and off world to
make things a little bit safer now after
everybody else have come in contact with
so far actually speaking to Daniel has
made me
quietly happy
and God forbid I don't want anyone to
lose their lives under my watch that is
my main job I do not want anybody to
lose their life and I'm absolutely
confident
that Daniel Jackson will be absolutely
fine messing with alien technology is
becoming a little bit of a problem and
it seems to be O'Neill two else he said
that again repeatedly in the post
incident interview I had
um they brought some mainly technology
back this ball thing that turned out to
be quite a nasty little weapon
um big spikes came out went straight
through and I threw him against a wall
pinned him anything and then we found
out that it's actually got these like
Nano or biominocular or tiny little life
forms everywhere
I and I just they just picked it up and
brought it back through the gate
I now have to do a house I now have to
write a risk assessment that says don't
bring alien stuff back that you don't
know what it does I know the idea of the
team is they're supposed to be going out
and Gathering technologies that can help
us fight the gold but I mean just don't
bring something back if you don't know
what it is
you know just
don't play with it
you find something that's useful bring
that back when you know what it is
other than that though
don't play with it
I I don't know how these people expect
me to be able to write these down risk
assessments when I'm having to write
don't play with alien technology as one
of the titles it's bad
apparently not all the gold are um bad
apparently there's these toker ones and
they're apparently all right
there is a retired military officer
that's now one of them
but it seems to have made him better so
that's fine
so I don't think
I need to do risk assessment on them
just the other ones
instead of evil
that I have to figure out a risk
assessment for
still haven't figured out
anything beyond like wear a collar
but I'll keep working on it
he stuck his head
in an alien device
his whole head
I tell them don't play with alien
technology
I tell them don't bring them back to the
base unless you know it does I wrote a
risk assessment that's the best it's
always titled don't bring alien
technology back to the base unless you
know it does
so he he took that advice on board
O'Neill two Wells instead he stuck his
head
in an alien device
weirdly it didn't turn out that great
I've now found another alien species I
have to do a risk assessment ton they're
called the Asgard and they're incredibly
incredibly impowerful
um they might be even more powerful than
the goals and that's saying something so
don't annoy those little fellas is going
to be the title of that risk assessment
but
he put his head
in an alien device
Ed
never
in all my days of risk assessments and
trying to keep people safe that's all I
want to do I just want to keep people
safe
when you're writing a risk assessment
generally you rewrite them quite vaguely
you know you you allow people to have
common sense
but how
do you write a risk assessment
that involves the risk of time travel
what to do
in case of time travel
it's going to be long
I don't quite know where to start
maybe if I could time travel
My Future Self
could tell me
but I mean it's not just the risk of the
people there's the risk that they could
go back in time and destroy our timeline
I mean
I I wanted a job that was a challenge
but
so yeah
that happened
and nobody's seeing bothered either
everybody was all hey been back to the
60s that was nice
and then they jump to the Future as well
that was that's good
nobody's seeing fussed
I'm the one that's gonna write all the
reports and write and write the risk
assessment and then send this video log
back to
the oversight committee no nobody gives
a crap about that
it's gonna be so long